Ai and machine learning have transformed
how we live work and interact with
technology from virtual assistance to
autonomous vehicles machine learning is
revolutionizing every industry promising
groundbreaking advancement and
unimaginable possibilities but why
should you choose a career in machine
learning machine learning is not just a
passing Trend it's a seismic shift that
is reshaping our world and creating new
avenues for Innovation and discovery
by embracing a career in machine
learning you become a part of a dynamic
field that thrives on solving complex
problems pushing boundaries and making a
profound impact on society the demand
for machine learning Engineers is
skyrocketing across industries from
Healthcare and finance to entertainment
and transportation organizations are
actively seeking talented individuals
who can harness the power of AI and
machine learning to drive their
businesses forward
but what does it take to become a
machine learning engineer how can you
embark on this thrilling Journey we have
the answers to all your questions so hey
everyone and welcome to Simply learn in
this video we'll take you through the
road map of how to become a machine
learning engineer but before we begin if
you enjoy watching these videos and find
them attractive then subscribe to our
YouTube channel because we bring the
best videos for you daily and press the
Bell icon to never miss any update from
Simply loan if you want to become an AI
expert and gain handsome salary packages
look at a wide range of AI and machine
learning courses by simply learn in
collaboration with the top universities
across the globe by enrolling in any of
these certification programs you will
gain expertise in skills like generative
AI prompt engineering CH GPD explainable
AI machine learning algorithms
supervised and unsupervised learning
model training and optimization and
there's much more on on the list with
hands-on experience in tools like chat
GPT Dal python open CV and tensorflow
you will catch the eye of top recruiters
so what are you waiting for hurry up and
enroll now a year of experience is
preferred to enroll in these courses so
check out the link mentioned in the
description box below for more details
so before we move on to how to become an
ml engineer in 2024 let's take a quick
look at what machine learning is machine
learning is the technique of creating
systems that can analyze pre-existing
data and learn patterns and make
decisions predictions classifications or
other tasks on the similar data with
minimal human
intervention as humans learn from the
experiences of the past to make better
decisions in the future machine learning
is the technique of training a computer
to learn from historical data to perform
tasks for us in a better manner in the
future moving forward let's see the
steps to Master machine learning and
become a machine learning
engineer first establish a strong
foundation in mathematics and
programming start by gaining a solid
understanding of critical mathematical
Concepts such as linear algebra calculus
and probability Theory additionally it
is crucial to become proficient in a
programming language like python which
is commonly used in machine learning and
develop coding skills next pursue a
degree in relevant field earn a
bachelor's or a master's degree in
computer science data science machine
learning or a related discipline to
acquire a comprehensive understanding of
AI principles and techniques moving on
to step number three acquire knowledge
in machine learning and deep learning
familiarize yourself with machine
learning algorithms neural networks and
deep learning Frameworks for example
tensorflow and pytorch to train and
optimize models using real world data
sets afterward engage in Practical
projects G Hands-On experience and
demonstrate your skills by working on
machine learning projects building a
portfolio of projects that showcase your
ability to solve machine learning
problems can make a strong impression on
potential employers moving on to the
next step collaborate and network engage
with AI communities attend conferences
and participate in online forums to
connect with Professionals in the field
collaborating with others can enhance
your learning experience and open up new
opportunities moving on to the next step
seek internships or entry-level
positions gain practical experience
through machine learning internships or
entry-level roles in industry or
research
institutions this will provide valuable
exposure and help you further develop
your skills moving on to the last step
we have continuously learn and adapt in
the fastpaced world of machine learning
it is crucial to stay updated on new
developments explore specialized areas
and embrace emerging Technologies and
tools continuous learning and
adaptability are essential IAL for
pursuing a successful career as a
machine learning engineer now that you
are familiar with the steps involved in
the Journey of a machine learning
engineer let's have a look at the roles
and responsibilities of a machine
learning engineer for those who wants to
become a machine learning engineer the
roles and responsibilities of a machine
learning engineer includes understanding
and using computer science fundamentals
including data structures algorithms
computability and complexity and
computer architecture using mathematical
skills for performing computations and
working with the algorithms involved in
this kind of programming producing
project outcomes and isolating issues
that require resolution to make the
program more effective collaborating
with the data as to build data and model
pipelines managing the infrastructure
and data pipelines that are necessary
for bringing code to production now that
you are familiar with the steps involved
in the Journey of a machine learning
engineer along with the roles and
responsibilities let's have the look at
the Sal of a machine learning engineer
in the United States there is a
possibility that the salary will varry
depending on the company as well as the
level of knowledge and experience that
you bring with you top companies like
dice wfix Adobe and many more are hiring
machine learning engineers in the United
States according to glaso the average
salary for a machine learning engineer
is
$140,000 annually in the United States
the demand for machine learning engineer
in India has caught the attention of
major industry players with renowned
companies such as cognizant Salesforce
MasterCard and others actively seeking
to add these professionals to their
dreams according to glaso the national
average salary of a machine learning
engineer is rupees 12 lakhs perm in
India so in conclusion embracing machine
learning isn't just a choice it's a
strategic decision that can reshape how
your organization approaches machine
learning with that being said we have
come to the end of this video if you
have any any questions regarding any
topic we have covered in this video then
please feel free to put them down in the
comment section below and our team of
expert will definitely answer them for
you as soon as possible so thank you so
much for being here we'll see you next
time until then keep learning and stay
tuned to Simply learn staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simplylearn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here